[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle thomas robert j'ai
24 ans et je suis une millennials alors
pourquoi une millennials parce que je
suis né entre les années 80 et 2000 du
coup j'ai découvert internet depuis ma
plus tendre enfance j'ai découvert grâce
à mon père qui jouent à des jeux vidéo
en ligne
alors je suppose que world of warcraft
doit parler à certains d'entre vous en
tout cas j'ai pu passer des heures d un
sa chaise à le regarder jouer à me
languir d'enfin pouvoir jouer à mon tour
qui est arrivé un jour où j'ai grandi où
j'ai le droit d'aller sur l'ordinateur
et puis j'ai commencé à jouer
et puis un jour j'ai encore grandi et
j'étais arrivé au collège alors au
collège c'était la mode à voir des blogs
coup j'ai eu un ou deux trois quatre
blog
puis-je encore dans 10 et puis je me
suis inscrit sur facebook sur twitter
puis j'ai commencé à acheter des choses
en ligne à lire des articles de presse
des articles de recherche est
aujourd'hui j'imagine internet comme une
immense sphère dans laquelle il y aurait
une multitude étoiles filantes et dans
chacune de chacune de ces étoiles
filantes serait l'un de nous connecter
sur le réseau en train de découvrir de
partager
mais aujourd'hui je me suis fait une
remarque j'ai l'impression que le web
connaît j'ai l'impression qu'il me
ressemble
on va me proposer d'acheter la dernière
paire de bottines sur laquelle j'ai
flashé vous d'écouter l'album de des
rolling stones que j'ai déjà écouté 150
x ou encore de lire un article
susceptibles de m'intéresser et je vous
demande comment c'est possible
comment c'est possible que le web qui
est si immense six géants puisse me
connaître moi petit individu parmi
presque 4 milliards d'utilisateurs
quotidiens
et bien c'est me connaît sa cause des
algorithmes alors je sais les
algorithmes c'est un mot barbare mais ça
peut être comparée tout simplement à une
recette de cuisine et dans une recette
de cuisine vous avez des ingrédients et
quand vous voulez mais l'ange est d'une
certaine manière ça crée un plat sur le
web ces ingrédients ça peut être par
exemple votre historique
ça peut être des données que vous avez
laissé sur un site ce qu'on appelle des
cookies ou des données que vous avez
laissé dans un formulaire comme votre
nom votre prénom votre email
ces algorithmes aujourd'hui ils servent
à créer des systèmes de recommandations
de personnalisation
ça permet de faire le tri dans
l'immensité de contenu qu'on peut
trouver sur le web aujourd'hui tout ça
dans le but de rendre votre vie
numérique plus facile plus agréable plus
limpide et on s'en doute pas mais google
est un immense système de
recommandations en fait il vous fournit
des résultats personnalisés grâce à
environ une soixantaine indicateurs
parmi lesquels on peut trouver la marque
de votre ordinateur
le navigateur que vous utilisez votre
localisation ou votre historique
mais alors qu'est ce qui se passe quand
sur la quasi totalité des sites que vous
consultez il ya des systèmes de
recommandations et de personnalisation
et ce sont des contenus que vous
consommez du coup et bien ça c'est un
phénomène qu'on appelle la bulle de
filtres alors je vous comparer le web
comme une immense faire dans laquelle il
y aurait une multitude étoile filante
alors imaginez qu autour de chacune de
ces étoiles
il est une petite bulle qui se forme
vous l'avez compris ces petites bulles
sont nos bulles de fil ce sont nos
propres univers sur le web
mabulle s'étend aussi bien de facebook à
mon twitter au monde à tripadvisor même
ou à la fourchette
et cette bulle elle est perçue par
certains comme une forme de prison
invisible parce que on ne voit que ce
qu'on connaît
on ne consomme que ce qui nous intéresse
déjà et c'est un petit peu vrai
finalement pour caricaturer mais à peine
les gens qui vont voter à droite ont
plutôt tendance à lire le figaro
et les gens qui vont voter à gauche
auront plutôt tendance à lire libération
en fait on passe notre temps à confirmer
qu'on a raison plutôt de pouvoir penser
qu'on a tort mais on a quand même besoin
savoir qu'on a tort par exemple il ya un
certain nombre d'années on pensait que
les trains ne pourrait pas rouler à plus
de 23 kilomètres heure sinon les
passagers moore est étouffée et
heureusement aujourd'hui quelqu'un est
allé à l'encontre de cette idée sinon on
n'aurait pas le bonheur d'utiliser la
sncf
enfin même quand on souhaite sortir
d'une bulle de filtres c'est parfois pas
facile j'ai dû effectuer un jour une
recherche sur les conspirationnistes
donc su aller sur youtube et puis j'ai
regardé des vidéos éditées par ces
conspirationnistes et quasi
immédiatement après sur youtube on me
suggérer d'aller découvrir comment le
world trade center n'avaient été qu'une
illusion
comment ben laden n'avait jamais été
tués par l'armée américaine mais se
cacher dans une cave en ac en
afghanistan ou comment michael jackson
était tout simplement jamais mort enfin
quoiqu'il en soit aujourd'hui on est de
plus en plus nombreux à penser que la
technique nous conditionnent qu'elle
conditionne notre rapport aux choses
parce que c'est vrai on ne comprend pas
forcément ce qu'ils ont dans le ventre
ses algorithmes on ne comprend pas tous
ces mots barbares issus de
l'informatique et du coup on a
l'impression de pas avoir de contrôle
mais si on avait dû contrôler et si on
n'était pas seulement des victimes mais
aussi un petit peu complice de ce
phénomène
alors ce que moi je vous propose ce soir
c'est aussi de prendre un petit peu de
recul sur nos comportements afin de un
petit peu dé diaboliser cette technique
alors déjà avant de parler de bulle dans
le web
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas parler de
bulle dans la réalité parce qu'on fait
souvent les mêmes choses on va souvent
dans les mêmes bars dans les mêmes
restaurants dans les mêmes magasins et
je pense qu'on est nombreux ici à former
une petite routine alors je sais pas si
vous êtes comme vous comme moi mais
quand je vais faire mes courses j'ai
toujours mon petit chemin prédéfini
alors samedi ou dimanche consorts jeu
vers intermarché et puis je commence à
reprendre les légumes puis après je
passe aux conserves puis après je passe
au pad puis après je passe au gâteau
après je vais payer
et puis après une fois que je sortais
d'intermarché je vais chez le boucher et
ensuite je vais la boulangerie et là
j'ai terminé ma routine pour ceux qui
vont travailler en voiture par exemple
prennent toujours le même chemin les
mêmes voies les mêmes passages les mêmes
raccourcis
enfin on cherche à créer une routine
dans nos vies parce qu'on cherche aussi
à économiser de l'énergie pour placer
cette énergie dans des choses qui nous
paraissent plus importante
et puis c'est aussi déstabilisant de
casser sa routine je suis retourné il ya
une semaine sur intermarché et il avait
changé tous les rayons j'ai passé vingt
minutes de plus à faire mes courses
enfin sur le web ont fait la même chose
on va avoir les mêmes sites on va avoir
les mêmes contenus
on va souvent voir les mêmes avis en
fait sur le web on on suit les mêmes
mécanismes de reproduction sociale que
dans la réalité on se rapproche de ce
qu'on connaît déjà de ce qui nous
intéresse déjà en charge d'une proximité
dans les autres et dans ce qu'on
consomme parce qu'on est quand même
relativement hostile voire réticents
voire hostiles au point de vue qui sont
différents du nôtre et c'est là qu'on
contribue à créer cette bulle
égocentrique mais cette bulle elle peut
être utile pour nous je savais pas quel
bottines met ce soir
alors je suis allé voir sur cinquantaine
de sites
puis alors j'en ai trouvé une vingtaine
de paires mais s'en retournant sur
facebook qu'on m'a proposé une publicité
ciblée avec une seule vert et c'était la
peur qu'il me fallait
je vais prendre un exemple qui est
souvent utilisé pour critiquer la télé
réalité mais qui peut aussi bien
s'adapter à notre sujet ces exemples du
truman show truman est enfermé dans une
vraie bulle est dans son monde tout est
fait que pour lui tout est artificielle
tout ne va que dans son sens ce monde
est lisse sans défauts mais il est
heureux il ne souffre pas et c'est
peut-être pour cette raison qu on se
complaît dans nos bulles parce que dans
nos bulles on se protège des attaques
potentielles on se protège ce qu'on ne
comprend pas de ce qui nous dépasse que
ce qui nous sort de notre zone de
confort en fait on ne prend pas de
risque c'est un exemple aussi peut-être
un petit peu banal mais le dimanche soir
j'ai souvent au temps de regarder des
films
alors j'ai une immense liste de films ou
documentaires qui serait très
enrichissant qui pourrait vraiment
enrichir ma culture personnelle et donc
ce dimanche soir je me retrouve devant
netflix qui me propose d'un côté ce
genre de documentaire très enrichissant
qui pourrait ou prendre aux tripes et
puis de l'autre côté un film avec
schwarzenneger donc je me doute bien ce
que je vais trouver dans le film de
schwarzennegger jeu surtout trouver de
la bagarre des coups de pied des
immeubles qui explosent et du feu
partout
et bien souvent je me dis ok on est
dimanche soir demain on est lundi demain
j'ai commencé une nouvelle semaine ça va
être suffisamment éprouvant comme ça
alors je me lance à fond dans le film
avec schwarzenegger
enfin vous me direz pourquoi est ce que
je veux sortir de cette bulle parce que
finalement c'est pas si grave de
regarder un blockbuster un peu moyen le
dimanche soir puis ils ont quand même
pas mal c'est boutinon mes problèmes de
la bulle c'est qu'elle nous livre à nos
propres faiblesses
6 1 dimanche soir j'ai regardé ce
blockbuster un peu moyen alors le lundi
soir elle va me proposer un autre puis
le mardi soir et ça va être
exponentielle
elle va me proposer 2 puis 4 8 puis 16
et puis on s'en sort plus en fait la
bulle c'est comme un miroir
ça nous reflète à un moment mais ça ne
prend pas en compte toutes nos
possibilités toutes nos facettes toute
l'envergure de nos personnalités sortir
de sa bulle sait aussi sortir de sa cave
et d'ignorance c'est aussi acquérir une
autonomie intellectuelle à prendre par
soi même c'est élargir son champ de
réflexion
et si on doit parler d'un point de vue
plus sociétale plus civique c'est quand
on argumente quand on forme une société
qu'on devient humain et ça s'est mis à
mal quand on se replie sur soi parce
qu'on tire vers le bas cette société
conforme encore aujourd'hui une société
et sa forme par nature en communauté et
à l'extrême on pourrait devenir qu'une
masse d'individus plutôt distincts les
uns des autres sans véritable lien et ça
ça me fait penser à des scénarios de
science-fiction ou des films de zombies
où on serait chacun de ces zombies
cherchant à manger les autres en tout
cas mon les à propre viande
si je dois reprendre l'exemple de truman
lorsqu'il apprend qu'il est dans une
bulle
ils ne cherchent qu'à en sortir mais il
apprend grâce à l'aide du personnage de
lorraine qui lui dit trop mal ça va pas
du tout tu es dans une bulle il faut en
sortir et c'est peut-être de ça dont on
aurait besoin nous aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être d'un coup de pouce un
encouragement et ça on pourrait le
trouver chez les gens du nudge alors le
neige à traduire comme ça ça veut dire
coup de coude encouragements et ça
consiste en une méthode douce
bienveillante
qui nous inciterait nous en tant
qu'utilisateur aux consommateurs à agir
mais pas sous la sanction pas sous la
contrainte et j'ai un exemple à vous
donner c'est celui de l'aéroport
d'amsterdam amsterdam il avait de trop
fortes dépenses en nettoyage dans les
toilettes pour hommes alors ce qu'ils
ont fait c'est qu'ils ont connaît un
petit sticker en forme de mouches en bas
des urinoirs et ça ça va inciter ces
messieurs a essayé de noyer et grâce à
cette technique
ils ont réussi à faire baisser les
dépenses en nettoyage de 80% c'est quand
même pas mal et sur le web par exemple
on peut avoir un autre type de neige
vous pouvez télécharger une petite
application qui s'appelle nage tout
bêtement et qui permet de vous dire
attention ça fait 45 minutes que tu
scroll sur facebook va faire autre chose
ou attention ça fait 45 minutes que tu
es sur twitter et que tu fais rien
d'autre
enfin si je dois encore vous dire une
chose ce soir c'est que c'est sur le web
qu'on a la plus grande opportunité de
rencontrer des opinions différentes de
nous d'opinions différentes de celles
qu'on rencontre actuellement dans nos
dans nos vies de manière régulière par
nos proches de cercle d'amis
alors laissez vous aller au la richesse
du web
on n'est pas maître des algorithmes
peut-être mais en tout cas on est
maîtres de nos bulles
alors si vous ne vous intéressez coup
jeu vidéo et c'est d'aller voir des
petits sujets en périphérique et saidal
et d'élargir votre bulle et puis laissez
vous aussi allez à la sérendipité du web
la sérendipité le fait de pouvoir
découvrir des contenus par le simple
hasard fait plus de 3 clics
alors sortez de vos bulles découvrir et
partager puiser dans les autres le
puiser dans vous même vous apprendrez
encore plus pour que la société grandit
c'est qu'on puisse grandir ensemble
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]